gavin newsom tiene la reputación de ser
un demócrata joven y carismático incluso
muchos en el partido alguna vez pensaron
que podía llegar a la casa blanca pero
ahora están luchando por su
supervivencia política como gobernador
de california con un triunfo abrumador
en los comicios de 2018 la popularidad
de newsan cayó en picada cuando en medio
de anunciar restricciones de kobe 19 fue
visto violando sus propias reglas en un
restaurante elegante sin mascarilla los
críticos recolectaron miles de firmas
que desencadenaron en la realización de
un referendo revocatorio para el 14 de
septiembre
si pierde por una simple mayoría
cualquiera de una lista no convencional
de candidatos podría tomar su lugar
dentro de los candidatos republicanos
está la ryder un presentador de radio de
derecha y ferviente partidario de trump
y por los demócratas la senadora diane
feinstein tiene 88 años y hay
especulaciones de que podría renunciar y
es parte de las razones por las que esta
elección podría tener repercusiones
nacionales el senado de eeuu está
dividido en un 50/50 con él de la
vicepresidenta kamala harris como
elemento crucial ahora aquí está el giro
si un republicano de strong a newsom y
feinstein deja el cargo el nuevo
gobernador llegaría a nombrar a su
reemplazo traspasando el control del
senado a los republicanos que luego
podrían bloquear cualquier proyecto que
la administración de bailén trate de
imponer los demócratas están preocupados
es lo último que necesitamos es tener a
algún gobernador de derecha en
california
una encuesta reciente reveló que los
votantes están igualmente divididos en
tres y newsome debe permanecer en el
cargo o no